I'm trying me the best everyone's got to  take I remember from high school into  college here in humans that we can be  able to translate my game to college in  an ounce of NBA whenever I'm able to get  by a defender and use a couple moves in  traffic in the other lane it's because  I've worked on it it's because I'm  uncomfortable with it  [Music]  you've worked so hard on your craft and  your handle that certain moves the game  just slows down for you  I think for me watching film is the best  part  technology today is definitely more  advanced in fact that you can get every  angle on one shot  it's just like a 360 video it's crazy  watching that's a great type needs to  get better it's not the normal thing  going in arenas hour and a half early no  I stuff a lot to work on a lot to get  better at that's the best part  there's definitely couple moves and love  back nothing people haven't seen yet